in a quiet residential street in west
london armed police are searching for a
man suspected of murder
residents were awoken by shouts and
bangs and watched as a 44 year old man
was led away
one of them told us what he'd seen
around one or half one in the morning
where i heard um
a huge bash
presumably it was the police with
the battering ram opening opening the
door of
the the resident opposite
and they just burst in with loads of
guns loads of like huge firearms
you know riot gear
this morning police and forensic suits
combed through the property in an
investigation that they described as
progressing at pace
the officer leading the investigation
said the arrest was a result of cctv
images shared on wednesday of the man
police urgently wanted to identify it's
thought mr o'halloran was stabbed in
broad daylight on tuesday he managed to
drive his mobility scooter 70 meters or
so to this street where he flagged a
passerby for help but tragically nothing
could be done to save his life
[Music]
a popular local figure
floral tributes to mr o'halloran were
laid outside the supermarket where he
used to play his accordion to raise
money for charity most recently for the
war in ukraine
london mayor city cannes visited the
local police station to be briefed on
the investigation
i can understand why all the londoners
are scared
you know it's really important uh that
at the community meeting tonight that
please give the reassurance uh they will
be given uh to those who are elderly uh
it's really important uh that there are
additional police officers that will be
policing this area over the next few
days that's an opportunity for somebody
with information to give that to the
police
mr o'halloran's death launched the sixth
murder investigation in just four days
in london the latest tragic tale in a
spate of summer violence across the
capital
matthew thompson sky news